hi there steve here
um yeah again today i had a hot plate
hockey this morning and now i have a
meeting in the office this afternoon so
and then uh mark and his family are
coming over bringing over some dinner
because of course i've been cooking for
my wife and so we're all gonna have
dinner and so
i don't know how much time i'm gonna
have for my korean today however people
have been asking for different language
uh you know for me to do videos in
different languages in spanish and so
forth so i'm gonna do one in spanish and
then one in japanese and i'm going to
talk about the challenge
how it's important to to concentrate to
focus that's what the challenge is all
about because language learning is a
function of how much time we spend with
the language
it's a matter of our attitude well the
attitude with me is i'm i'm motivated
and uh good content is particularly
motivating and i've found some now in
korean
and of course this ability to notice
and that uh
basically this supposedly pacific
activity of listening reading and
linking and so forth
does enable me to improve quite a bit
uh proof of which was that uh in just
one week my spoken korean improved quite
a bit now this week i haven't been doing
as much so i may not have that much
progress but that's in the nature of
language learning sometimes we feel we
do better sometimes we don't do so well
but we sort of go up and down but the
path always is that we continue to get
better as long as we spend time with the
language so something along those lines
i haven't quite decided what i'm going
to say is what i'm going to say first in
spanish and then in japanese and i don't
think we'll be able to put up um
you know subtitles and all because it's
just too much work we just don't have
time to do it i am sorry
bye for now